all right thank you so much for having
me today let me just start my timer so I
know how long I'm taking all right so
yeah my name is Brian Egan and I'm here
today to talk about flutter apps and
reactive architectures for flutter apps
and so just a little about myself I'm
currently an indie dev contract with the
Google team to write the flutter
cookbook and previously I used to work
at SoundCloud here in Berlin and before
that I also actually worked at Zappos
for a couple years in Las Vegas as well
so my experience kind of comes with
working from yeah medium-sized teams and
the types of architectures that fit well
for those teams so I think basically
what if you're kind of interested in
flutter you might be like oh this is
like a whole new thing but I think we
can actually take a lot of the lessons
we've learned from Android and the best
practices we've learned from Android and
actually apply them to flutter so if we
sort of think about the architectural
goals that we've seen that work on
Android right we've seen that layered
architectures are really really powerful
we've started to see like the power of
modularity as well of breaking our apps
down into smaller parts
you notice that independent teams can
work on those parts and then sort of
assemble them back together as a larger
app for us at Sound Cloud at least
testability was a huge deal and I think
that the architectures we create and
that we should be thinking about for
flutter I think you know if you're doing
a prototype or something maybe this
isn't as important but if you're getting
an app that's got a lot of users
millions of users maybe tens of millions
of users a month then testing is I think
pretty crucial and of course we want to
sort of follow the solid principles that
have stood the test of time and you know
it needs to handle all the normal bits
we need to be able to talk to databases
and web servers and we need to respond
to user interactions so you know I hope
this stuff doesn't sound too crazy or
too foreign and I think we can actually
apply this in a reactive way to flutter
apps so if you've sort of taken a spin
of flutter the building blocks that
flutter it gives you pretty quickly
you're gonna play with the stateful
widget now this is actually just really
the example taken when you do a flutter
create it'll actually generate like a
dart file for you and it'll have this
exact class
there and so all it does is you have a
stateful widget and it takes in some
properties so in this case it's going to
take in a title which is just a string
and then almost immediately it just gets
out of the way and creates this
companion object called a state class
and this is really where you implement
all the interesting stuff so we've got a
home page state class and inside of it
it's got a few different
responsibilities so it needs to define
the data model that this component or
widget will actually need to render then
you'll have some methods to update the
state as well and so in this case what
we'll do is when someone calls this
method what we'll do is we'll just
increment the counter and then right
after that we'll also wrap this in a set
state call and that'll tell flutter hey
some of the data for this widget has
changed
so please redraw it on the next frame
the third responsibility of the state
class is that you actually render the UI
itself so in this case you've got a
build method which returns a widget and
it essentially consumes the data that's
been passed in so it can consume the
title that we've passed in as well as
the local state that's contained within
the class so in this case we'll have a
text widget and it'll render the current
counter and we'll have a button and when
you press on that button it will call
the increment counter method that we
just showed you and then yeah floated
will redraw do its normal thing and so
yeah we're kind of rolling right
you could also even go ahead and get
crazy and start to put like Network
calls in there if you wanted to you know
if you're breathing into a paper bag
just don't worry we'll get there
so yeah let's like quickly challenge
this and see like hey our state class is
a good idea for this type of logic so I
don't know at least to me it felt like
there's a lot going on in this state
class when I first saw it and so I
thought okay let's just see how testing
works so what I was hoping to do is
write a pure dart tests you know just
saying that the counter can be
incremented I was hoping I could just
instantiate the state class directly
call the increment counter method and
then finally say okay I expect this to
counter to be one now instead of zero
the reality with flutter is actually
that if you want to put like business
logic type of things inside of your
state class it can get a bit trickier
because state classes are action
bound to the flutter framework this
means you actually need to use the
function that flutter provides called
test widgets and this will allow you to
essentially build the widget in this
case I'm building the entire app and
that's just for convenience then you
need to look through the widget tree and
you can say okay let's tap on that
button then you can say okay flutter I
know some state has changed so please
rebuild the UI and then you can finally
say okay can we look through the widget
tree and find the text that we expect so
if we just kind of return to our like
architectural goals checklist I think
it's pretty clear that we're not
layering stuff very well here we're sort
of putting you know UI logic we're
putting this actual like sort of state
object itself sorry not the state object
but the sort of state that this class
needs all in one place it could be
considered modular you know you could
have like you know your login team like
do their thing and then your search team
doing their thing but you know it might
not be the most modular it's testable to
a point but if you need to do more
intricate stuff it's gonna be difficult
it definitely doesn't follow solid
principles right we're like shoving a
lot of responsibilities into one class
and you could do all the normal bits but
maybe because it's not meeting that
other criteria it's not as great so my
personal conclusion from this was that
like actually this type of stuff is
really good for like UI or view logic
and it's it's perfectly fine for that
kind of stuff but you know it's also
really cool that widget testing is built
into flutter because it's actually a
really powerful way to write unit tests
for your view layer essentially but as I
said I think we're starting to mix a lot
of logic into one class we're mixing
your UI logic our domain logic and you
know if I had gotten crazy I was even
gonna mix the data logic in there and so
I think you can start to see we're
testing more complex scenarios so if you
have you know interesting list
transformations for example this type of
stuff is possible but it's going to be
more difficult and it's going to get
even Messier when async code is involved
because of the way test widgets works it
actually does some interesting stuff to
override the default async mechanisms in
dart which make it really a really good
fit for testing widgets but maybe not
testing collaborators that are async by
Nature
it also I don't know if this reminds
anyone else at this but it feels like a
little bit like a God activity where
you're just like throwing everything
into a single class and I think we've
seen that over time that's really
actually been a bit of a pain point for
some of us as we try to refactor our
apps if you're just putting way too much
stuff into one class so let's like
introduce some layering then right so
this is just standard stuff as I said
let's apply the best stuff from Android
to our flutter apps so let's break out
our a UI our domain and our data layer
and if we want to break this out a bit
further we can sort of do the
traditional sort of diagram where we
have a view talking to a presenter the
presenter talks to some sort of use case
or interactor at the domain layer you
know it will talk to some sort of data
layer in this case a repository and that
will be responsible for you know
fetching the data from the correct data
source and then it'll pipe all that
right back up up to the presenter into
the view so if we talk about flutter
then what we can talk about is we can
say okay the view layer is really the
widget layer and I'm going to be
discussing a concept so rather than a
presenter we'll just call it a block and
this stands for a business logic
component and this is yeah it's funny
because I'm putting in the UI layer the
Google team has called it a business
logic component I think we could debate
that but I know I really see it actually
as very similar to a presenter so
hopefully the stuff we look at when we
get to code won't look too crazy because
you'll kind of understand its purpose in
the hierarchy so if we dive in a little
more since we want this to be reactive
we want to be working with streams and
we'll talk a little bit about streams in
a couple minutes but they essentially
just represent values over time and if
you are familiar with Rx it's just
almost the exact same thing so you can
stream data to the block and then it can
go ahead and fetch any data that it
needs from the use case or interactor
layer the domain layer and then it can
pipe that straight back up to the view
maybe do some transformations if
necessary we also heard a few talks this
morning and so for folks maybe watching
this at home I'd really recommend
checking out some of the NBI and the
Mobius talks they're really interesting
but I think you can start to see this
will actually work a lot like those are
cat
right so you can actually use a block in
a similar way that you would use an MBI
presenter so let's take a look at how
this works so as I said it's based on
streams and streams were I think really
a great abstraction because they're
actually baked right into dart so you
actually get language levels support for
them
so they're these functions called async
star functions and they allow you to
sort of create and return streams in a
really nice way the other really big
benefit to this and this was actually
one reason that the Google team invented
this was because the ads words team at
Google I should say invented this is
because streams work on every platform
so they actually share about 50 to 60
percent of their code between their
flutter apps which are ios and android
and also they share it with their
angular dart apps so they're actually
able to share a huge amount of code in
between those platforms similar to
actually what Jake was talking about
this morning with sharing code the other
nice thing is it's got deep integration
into a lot of core libraries so you're
just going to run into streams in the
wild and as I said if you're working
with observables they're really similar
to observables they are a little bit
more limited than what rx Java or rxjs
provides so I've been working with
another collaborator on the Rx dart
library and this essentially brings more
power to the stream class so we just
extend the stream class and provide
additional operators we also provide an
implementation of subjects but just to
give you really what we're trying to do
is give an API that really feels a lot
like rx Java or rxjs with everything you
would expect from a stream stream
implementation so of course just like
you can subscribe to observables you can
listen to streams you can pass through
callback functions that should happen so
you know if the stream emits a data
event you would just do something with
that or an error event or a done event
and you can do whatever you need to do
in there so at this point I'm just
printing stuff it's pretty unexcited but
yeah this is just to give you a feeling
for how similar it is to observables
really you just subscribe to these
certain events and you get going you can
also create streams in a few different
ways you have your
stream constructors so you know this is
like if you want to create a stream from
an iterable or a future which is a nice
async primitive that's also baked into
Dart if you want to get more advanced
you can do concatenation or deferring
streams with rx start and there's a
quite a few of other more operators or
constructors that are useful but this is
just to give you a sample the other cool
thing as I said is you get language
level support for streams in dart and
this is a really interesting pattern
actually I think so
in this case we've got a function called
search and it takes in the search term
and the form of a string and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna mark this
function as being an async star function
which means that we're required to
return some type of stream and so in
this case I'm just gonna make the
example really silly and say okay we're
returning a string but I think you could
imagine you could return more complex or
more interesting objects from this type
of function and the cool thing is that
once you're inside this function alright
so once you're inside this function you
could actually use the yield keyword
nice it's working again so every time
you yield a value it will be emitted to
the listeners of this stream and this is
a really nice way so you can write kind
of maybe a little bit less like crazy rx
code and write maybe a little more
imperative code so this search what
we'll want to do is we'll want to emit a
loading event so that our you I can show
loading and then within a try-catch
block what we can do is we can actually
say hey let's go ahead and try to call
our search service and assume it returns
a future and we'll just wait for that
future to complete and if it completes
successfully will yield that value out
to the listeners of the stream but if it
fails for some reason we can emit an
error event so you know I think you
could think if you've worked with rx you
know I think you could model this in the
same way with rx very easily you know
you could you know do a start with
loading event and then you know on error
return you know the the error instead
but I think async functions are kind of
a nice way to clean that up actually and
the final way is with something called a
stream controller which is sort of glue
but
Queen the inputs and then outputs of a
stream so it provides a stream that you
can listen to and then you can also it
also provides what's called an events
sync and this allows you to add data to
the stream or errors or tell the stream
that hey this actually is done now and
so yeah so you've got these three
methods basically on the event sink add
a tear and close and those will of
course get sent to the places you would
expect the listener to receive them so
yeah so that's really nice and if you're
used to like rx observers so you're
working with maybe like a subject it's
almost the identical right you can kind
of see that ad sort of corresponds to on
next add error risk corresponds to on
error and close corresponds to the on
complete so this brings us back to the
block pattern that we were discussing so
as I said these stands for business
logic components and they've got a few
special rules and so this is really the
reason I was kind of describing stream
controllers especially is that sinks are
used for inputs so the view layer can
add data to a sink and then the block
can listen to the stream of that input
and react to it and then the block will
also send streams of data back to the
view layer and then the view layer can
actually subscribe to those streams and
update the state when that change or
update the view excuse me when that
stream changes and because this is meant
to be used cross-platform between
angulardart
and also flutter apps it's really
important that you don't inject any
dependencies like concrete
implementations but you inject abstract
in interfaces or abstract classes and
the reason you want to do that is
because if you're in the browser context
you can you know use like a browser HTTP
client if you're in flutter you can use
what's called the i/o client or if
you're in a test scenario you could
inject a mock client for example so if
we look at a basic block we'll just call
it a counter block and you know it'll
actually emit so if this is basically
the same thing as we had initially so
it'll emit a stream of integers that
we'll call a counter and then to get
data from the view layer it'll provide a
sink
and this is just called the increments
Inc and just to be good citizens you
definitely generally want to dispose of
your sinks when you're done with them so
say for example you have your showing a
view or showing a screen and then that
screen should go away you'll definitely
want to clean up after yourself so yeah
we'll just close off the sink when we're
done here and then what you can do is
under the hood actually the block can
use either less stream controller which
I just talked about or in this case I'm
going to use a published subject which
comes from rx start and actually
implements the stream controller
interface and the only reason I'm doing
that is because it gives you all of the
RX operators by default rather than
having to convert a stream into an
observable and then use those things so
yeah so we'll create a subject here and
then since we don't want to expose the
full subject to the view layer we'll
just and the subject I should say also
implements the sink interface so we'll
say ok we'll provide a sink to the view
layer by just basically aliasing subject
and reducing some of its capabilities
and in the counter stream we'll just
basically listen to the subject whenever
someone taps on that button and it'll
just run an accumulator function so in
this case we're using the scan keyword
and we're just adding to the previous
count every time a new tap comes in or
every time the subject emits some sort
of item so the cool thing is that these
are actually really testable so dart as
I said because streams are baked in you
actually get support with the testing
library as well so you can this is just
a trivial example but I think it shows
actually kind of how nice some of the
testing is so you can just say ok I've
got this stream and I expect it to emit
these values in order and so yeah if
you're worried about maybe your UI
emitting States in the wrong way you can
really easily test like hey is my stream
doing the right thing in the right order
you can actually also test errors as
well so you can say hey does this
observable or this stream does it emit
an error of a certain type or you know
you could provide more complex logic in
here this is exception is just a just a
matcher and you can write your own
matchers
to verify that you're getting the right
thing
and so we've talked a little bit about
the sort of block or the presenter layer
so what about flutter then like where
does it come into the picture well we
talked about it really being the view
layer and so what it can do is it can
actually render the data from a stream
using a class widget called a stream
builder and so this actually takes in
two parameters a stream and a builder
it's a stream builder
yeah what it says on the box so in this
case we'll pass through the counter
stream to this widget and then the
Builder function will actually return a
widget that's built up so you basically
take in the data that the stream emits
and you render a widget using that data
so this is really cool because then you
know whenever it changes you can just
create a new widget hierarchy and
flutter will take care of rendering that
to the screen you don't really need to
think about setting up subscriptions or
do any doing anything like that the
other thing is we can do is of course we
want to be able to send data back to the
block so that it can run that
accumulator function and increase the
count and so what we'll do is we'll say
okay since we've got a sink that we can
use we'll just add data to the sink yeah
when it's when it's ready to go so I
think what we can do is we can kind of
look at our check list again and we can
start to see that we're layering our
architectures in a better way it's more
modular it's definitely much more
testable then then we saw before I we
couldn't we didn't get into all of that
but you can definitely see how testable
it is we can definitely follow the solid
principles here we're segregating
responsibilities we're injecting
abstract interfaces rather than concrete
classes etc and of course you can do all
the normal stuff you can still talk to
web api's this is a really smaller small
example but you can definitely do all
the all the powerful things so yeah my
conclusion from this is that first of
all there's no reason for us you know I
really like flutter and I think it's
really fun but there's no reason for us
to like reinvent the architectural wheel
in some ways like we have really good
patterns that were used to from Android
that work well for statically typed
languages and we can actually use all of
these normal patterns that we've used in
the past and combine them with some
the things that dart offers out of the
box like streams and we can combine
these to make really powerful
architectures that are easy to test easy
to work with and also allow us to share
a great deal of code between even
angulardart apps if you want to go that
route so yeah I'll post these slides
afterwards but to get look at more
advanced examples I've got some
different examples up here some of these
come from the flutter team other the
other are ones that I've done there's
also more talks on the block pattern
itself so yeah once again you can check
these links out and thank you very much
thanks you Brian
[Applause]